[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum sportwart dem
sport podcast des österreichischen
bundesheers mein name ist andreas on air
ich bin selber herr sportlern wir wollen
euch hier beim sport report die vielen
spannenden geschichten hinter den tollen
persönlichkeiten der harrah's
sportlerinnen und herr des sportlers
näher bringen
heute zu gast bei mir ein team kollege
von mir mein kollege pfarrer schwimmteam
andreas hofer einer von zwanzig
behinderten sportlerinnen und
behindertensportler beim bundesheer
herzlich willkommen liebe an die hand
wir haben oder nicht mehr andere
gemeinsamkeiten der name sticht
natürlich hervor aber genauso wie du
habe auch ich eine behinderung und wir
sind gemeinsam kollegen beim herres
sport jetzt erst einmal für die die uns
zuhören und ich nicht sehen was hast du
für eine behinderung und wie es dazu
gekommen
natürlich haben wir 2014 drei halswirbel
gebrochen
seitdem sieht sich jetzt im rollstuhl
aber eine so jeden komplette
querschnittslähmung
und dazu ist es gekommen schwimmen also
auch wieder sehr naheliegend dass ein
köpfe ins wasser wobei es nicht ganz so
klassisch ist wie man das kind war ich
dabei nicht am boden aufgekommen bin das
war bei einem see den ich ihnen und
auswendig kennen wenn dort rein guckt
jedes mal von einer mit der höhe und nur
mit der wasseroberfläche spannung habe
ich mir dann leider trüben zerbröselt
sodass ich habe den brustwarzen abwärts
nichts mehr spüren nichts mehr bewegen
haben können das heißt damit man sich
das auch wirklich ganz genauer vorstellt
du bist nirgendwo dagegen kalt sondern
einfach der eintrag winkel am wasser war
gerade so blöd dass es zum wirbel buch
geführt hat wie wahrscheinlich ist es
dass sowas passiert ja ich nehme mal an
das ist extrem unwahrscheinlich hoffe
ich zumindest ich wünsche ihnen und den
krankenhaus ärzten zu mir gesagt ich
hätte otto springen sondern ist das
schwimmen oder lotto sechser
wahrscheinlicher gewesen
wir haben hier auch lieber gewesen wenn
ich ehrlich bin aber beim nächsten mal
werde ich zu machen
es ist wie sie ist und man muss
natürlich das beste daraus machen
wir können uns natürlich besser und
deswegen frage ich auch genau nach weil
ich einfach weißt dass du auch gerne
hoffen eine geschichte erzählt weil
damit auch menschen mit der seite geben
möchte
wie war das am unfallort selbst passiert
der unfall tut auch scott ins wasser ein
hast du noch erinnerungen an all das was
danach passiert ist wie ist es dort frau
hat alles zugegangen
ja ich wäre sehr gern offen darüber weil
ich glaube dass andere menschen
vielleicht doch viel mitnehmen können
und im prinzip ich bin nicht die
einzigen stellen klo macht und es kann
gleich mal was passieren
für mich was damals ein kämpfer jeder
andere wie gesagt das waren
wahrscheinlich da eine million cad mich
dort gemacht habe von einer mit der höhe
ist hat anscheinend nicht so einsam und
ich habe es auch nicht bemerkt dass was
passiert ist ich habe keine schmerzen
und nichts gehabt für mich was dank
komisch wie ich unter wasser war die
wasseroberfläche spannung also was wir
gesehen die wasserfläche und aber nicht
hinkommen und bin natürlich wollten rom
schwimmen aber ich habe leider jahren
die beine nicht mehr bewegen können
ich bin dass ich nach rom gekommen und
habe das nicht gewusst ich habe das
jetzt merklich nach unten geschaut haben
uns bewegt sich nichts und man gott sei
dank meiner cousins dabei und habe mich
dann gleich aus dem wasser gefischt und
da man dann gemerkt dass was nicht
stimmt dass ich hab die berührungen von
ihnen zwar gesehen aber nicht gespürt
wir haben nicht gar nicht bewegen können
eben wie gesagt aber leider nicht und
das dokument muss ja bestimmt irgendwas
nicht ich weiß nicht was es ist und dann
schon der ganze rettungskette begonnen
das hätten seine cousins auch nicht
schnell reagiert und gecheckt dass daran
die normalerweise nicht so lange unter
wasser ist dann hätte das alles auch
noch anders ausgehen können also in dem
sie noch viel glück gehabt wir freuen
uns natürlich dass nichts schlimmeres
passiert ist wir wanderten die tage
wochen monate nach dem unfall für dich
du warst ja relativ jungen wie das
passiert ist
wie ist es dir damit gegangen ja das ist
extrem schwer zu beschreiben und
natürlich sehr viel auf einmal auf mich
zu stoßen ist ich war damals 17 jahre
alt ja jetzt was für mich so komme ich
noch nicht viel weiter fragen ob ich
dann traurig war oder wie ich kleiner
das war für mich ganz komisch ich war
dann im krankenhaus auf die
intensivstation natürlich nach der
notoperation
wir haben dann relativ schnell viele
leute besucht also die familie die
engsten freunde und das war so komisch
weil alle die mich besucht haben damit
ich meine kraft in den sieben schätzung
sehen ich habe nicht bewegen und zum
weinen begonnen und viele halt und das
war dann so dass ich
der betroffene hatten die leute die mich
besucht haben trösten müssen nicht
gewollt sein dass es nicht zu schlagen
und mir geht es gut ich habe keine
schmerzen
also und das ist halt irgendwie komplett
komisch weil eigentlich gekommen sind
dass sie mir mut zusprechen
das hat mich dann auch irgendwie
bestärkt würde ich natürlich auch mir
selber dann haben wir ganz gut und durch
die unterstützung von freunden familie
und meine feuerwehrkameraden nämlich
auch sehr viel besuchten im krankenhaus
aber ich dann gott sei dank geschafft
dass ich in der reha wieder sehr viel
weitergebracht habe und sehr viel was
man körper herausholen können
trotz der fr gesagt das unterwasser
gemerkt dass das du weder beine noch
arme bewegen konnte
jetzt kannst du deine arme wieder
bewegen wie funktioniert das genau dass
das funktion zurück kommt oder dass man
diese wieder erlangt ich nehme mal an
das hat auch viel mit der therapie in
der rehabilitation zu tun wie war das
bei dir ja das ist mit den wirbelkanal
ganz kompliziert also da sind sehr viele
leitungen sowie reseller und je nachdem
was teils beschädigt so etwas nicht kann
man dann dass sich spüren bewegen was
auch immer ich habe das glück dass bei
mir das rückenmark nicht komplett
durchtrennt war dann hätte ich sehr
wenig chancen sondern dass zumindest ein
paar verbindung nach geblieben sind
und so kommt es dass ich jetzt
mittlerweile auch die arme wieder
relativ gut bewegen kann
es war sehr viel therapie also ich habe
direkt aber nur für ein halbes jahr reha
gemacht und seitdem jedes jahr
mindestens ein monat immer in den
schulferien welche damals noch spieler
war
und ja gott sei dank die viel therapie
und hat der arbeit ich habe auch gute
voraussetzungen gehabt muss man dazu
sagen ich war jung ich war motiviert
über sportlich ist alles natürlich für
mich gesprochen und soll es kommen dass
ich mich dann wieder zurück ins leben
arbeiten haben können
du hast jetzt auch die therapie
angesprochen dass auch der grund warum
du zum schwimmsport gekommen bist wie es
das genau passiert ist das abgelaufen
eigentlich gar nicht gleich direkt
sondern sehr stimmig rollstuhl rugby
gespielt also auch eine sehr coole
sportart ist aber irgendwann hat dann
mein physiotherapeut sinne gemeint das
ist ein bisserl widersprüchlich dass wir
jede woche trainieren dass ich
irgendwann vielleicht sogar aus dem war
schon mal wieder rauskommen und dann mit
meiner freizeit bin ich die muskulatur
fürs autofahren
was haben wir dann zum nachdenken
irgendwie gebracht
und dann hab ich euch an weiß noch
kennengelernt den schwimmverein habe
dann damit trennen dürfen und das hat
mir sehr viel spaß gemacht die erst eine
folge war gott sei dank relativ bald da
was natürlich sportler immer motivierend
ist und dadurch dann die entscheidung
treffen müssen wir ein rugby oder
schwimmen
wir möchten verschwimmen entschieden
gott sei dank hat zutage und ja es macht
mir sehr viel spaß und ich bin auf dem
richtigen weg zur zeit jetzt ist es für
mich immer faszinierend wenn ich mit
menschen zu tun habe die einen unfall
hatten zum beispiel beim snowboarden und
dann werden die profi snowboarder oder
jemand hat einen unfall beim schwimmen
und dann wird der schwimmer ja wie kann
man sich das salz nicht dass sportler
oder nicht sportlerin vorstellen dass
man genau das macht wo man sich
eigentlich die behinderung angeeignet
hat wie war das bei dir ein bisschen
verrückt sein
er wisse aber einfach keine angst haben
also bei mir war es so dass ich den see
gekannt habe dort jeden sommer bei
meiner oma dort ein haus hat ich habe
das so so so viele schöne erinnerungen
mit meinen freunden familie und ich
wollte das alles nicht von dem negativen
event überschatten lassen und so ist es
auch gekommen dass ich wirklich auf den
tag genau ein jahr nach dem unfall
wieder dorthin verwiesen zudem sehe habe
ich damals noch nicht so gut bewegen
können durch die freunde mehr dorthin
gebracht sich jetzt einmal aber was ganz
wichtig dass ich am tag genau ein jahr
danach der wieder ins wasser gehen
und weil ich einfach wieder die
positiven verbindung zu dem ort haben
wollte und auch das wasser hat mir im
prinzip nichts getan also das war
einfach ein begriff die wasseroberfläche
das war s das selber kann jetzt nichts
dafür und ich freue sich darauf das
wasser der ganzen welt böse sein und so
bin ich jetzt beim schwimmen gerne
wasser und habe das richtige für mich
damals leider der auslöser für den
unfall war und es trägt sich in dem
sinne jetzt zu neuen erfolgen dazu
kommen wir gleich etwas angesprochen was
noch schüler wiederum für passiert ist
jetzt dann mit mit 17 den unfall zu
haben nach einer harten reha wieder
einen alltag einzusteigen wie war da die
umstellung für dich mal abgesehen von
sport und therapie wirklich im
lebensalltag mit einer behinderung das
leben jetzt anzugehen
ja es war extrem schwer sowie ein halbes
jahr fr
hätte eigentlich noch länger bleiben
soll aber ich wollte unbedingt wieder
ins schuljahr einsteigen weil ich
einfach meine freunde nicht verlieren
wollte und auch die schulgasse nicht und
habe damals ist er dann in absprache mit
den ärzten so dass dann unterbrochen
wenn nicht sagen abgebrochenen
unterbrochen wenn einem semester in die
schule eingestiegen was extrem habe weil
ich habe ein halbes jahr in der del
verpasst kann man sich denken dass
einiges passiert habe dann die sachen
mitmachen müssen aber alles nachmachen
müssen also dass mein wahnsinn hat die
unterstützung von freunden ich das dann
habe ich es gut geschafft bin in den
sommerferien jetzt einwohner damit nach
freiheit gewesen wieder trainieren dann
wird in der schule weitermachen
also es war eine sehr harte zeit ich
habe wenig zeit für mich gehabt das war
wirklich nur lernen und übungen therapie
machen
ich würde es auch selber nicht mehr so
machen ich würde niemanden empfehlen
man soll sich zuerst die zeit für
therapie nehmen und wenn meine einer
schule verliert ist es auch egal ob
andere verlieren das ja weil sie nichts
lernen auch schon so ich war damals ja
ich wollte unbedingt mitmachen hat es
gott sei dank geschafft habe dann mit
meiner klasse wirklich maturiert so
können wir da einen guten erfolg
gratulieren und ja es war sehr hart das
war sehr viel arbeit aber ich bin froh
dass wir zum ende und geschafft habe und
dann ist es ja relativ rasch und schnell
gegangen mit den erfolgen bei dir du
hast angefangen mit nationalen
wettkämpfen dann erst der internationale
wettkämpfe und gleich bei seinem ersten
großereignis bei der europameisterschaft
2008 sind habe ich ja hautnah miterleben
dürfen und und dich anfeuern dürfen am
beckenrand hast du die bronzemedaille
gewonnen
wie war das für dich gleich beim
allerersten mal wo man wahrscheinlich
selber keinerlei erwartungen hat oder
selber nicht weiß was man erwarten soll
gleich am podium zu stehen es war
unglaublich es ist markant mit worten
nicht beschreiben ich kann nur versuchen
ich bin zu der europameisterschaft
hinkommen wenn das kaum retter neuling
war weit weg von einer mitteilung
kandidat
man sieht was er sich bei einem bewerb
vielleicht irgendwie das finale erreicht
weil ich einen guten tag habe ich hab
sogar bei allen wir haben ins finale
geschafft und nebenbei 50 meter brust
die brawns metalle oder ich schlag am
ende an und leute die uns fahren sehen
uns das bild-interview leider nicht das
beschreibt im moment ziemlich gut wie
ich das glück in den augen hat mich
unendlich frei keine kraft mit den
arbeiten aber es ist einfach die freude
die so groß ist dass man sich dann frei
und ich habe drei mal überprüfen auf der
anzeigetafel ob ich wirklich den dritten
platz habe und das war unglaublich schön
und das war auch der punkt wo ich dann
für mich nach entschieden ob das jetzt
das schwimmen wirklich hauptmesse
studierenden bei noch der punkt wo ich
sage dass das schwimmen quasi mein
studium überholt hat also ich war jetzt
wirklich das macht das studium der mann
steht und jetzt schwimmen mittlerweile
sogar mein hauptberuf ist gott sei dank
das ist ja auch so weit jetzt her dass
sportler die möglichkeit hast wie kann
man sich sarah schwimmen das ja für
viele noch nicht so aktuell im alltag
kann man sich ungefähr den tagesablauf
eines profis vorstellen und was macht
eigentlich die faszination kader
schwimmen für dich genau aus der
tagesablauf wie ist jetzt nicht so
kompliziert ich bekomme da haben wir
einen ziemlich genauen plan von meinem
trainer dasteht gar ziemlich genau dem
was ich zu tun habe
ich habe gott sei dank das gerät mit dem
bundes patienten mit natürlicher dass
ich da perfekt trainieren kann
habe dort kann dort essen gehen kann er
trainieren gehen
das passt alles ist optimal für mich und
so versuche ich mich darauf für jeden
wert kommt wie man neue vorzubereiten
trainings zyklen und jetzt sonders groß
jetzt natürlich die bau lübecks nächstes
jahr
und so läuft ihr woche für woche und ich
schaue dass ich von tag zu tag besser
wird
was fasziniert dich jetzt genau am paar
schwimmen was ist warum würdest du sagen
heißt der beste sportler welt wenn ich
jemand fragen würde ja ob es da besser
sportwelt ist weiß ich nicht das ist
zumindest für mich ein geiler sport und
ob es gott sei dank für mich gefunden
ich hoffe das sonst so leichter normal
schwimmen können und nicht bloß wenn
sogar ist das coole ist dass wir trotz
unserer einschränkung da genau das
gleiche machen wie die nicht behindert
uns jetzt einmal die schwimmtechnik ist
recht des landes aber wir geben unser
bestes video und einen harten
trainingsalltag
das ist einfach schön dann von wettkampf
zu wettkampf zu fliegen die leute kennt
man schon aus der weltspitze wenn sie
immer wieder die gleichen sind wenn man
sich mit ihnen austauschen was neues
gibt und wenn man die erfolge auch noch
stimmen ist das natürlich
unbeschreiblich und man hat alles
richtig gemacht du bist einer von
zwanzig herres sportlerinnen und
sportlern mit behinderung beim
bundesheer das ist ja seit 16 möglich
davon profitiere ich ja genau so und wir
trainieren ja auch gemeinsam in der
südstadt was mich so fasziniert ist
diese alltägliche begegnung auf
augenhöhe
mit unseren olympischen kolleginnen und
kollegen wie hast du das jetzt
wahrgenommen in deiner zeit in den
eineinhalb jahren seitdem du jetzt beim
herner spa zentrum ist sehr positiv also
ich habe sehr lange auf dem platz beim
mehr sport warten müssen ob dafür
gekämpft gab es dann mit browns mit bei
der europameisterschaft gott sei dank
geschafft
das ist einen platz bekommen habe und
dadurch habe ich jetzt einfach optimale
trainingsbedingungen in der südstadt und
nicht mehr die trainingsbedingungen
zwischen angesprochen hast einfach auch
die kontakte also man hat einfach zu
anderen bis jetzt behindert oder nicht
behindert nicht ganz egal was andere top
sportlern man trifft sich immer wieder
man kann sich austauschen und ich denke
dass das zusätzlich zu den
trainingsbedingungen einfach auch sehr
wertvoll ist immer da
kontakt miteinander hält glaubst du dass
andere athleten und athletinnen etwas
anderer lernen können
ich hoffe dass nicht nur gelesen sondern
allgemein verschiedenen menschengruppen
vielleicht was von mir lernen können so
dass er sich versucht dass ich so viel
wie möglich durch meine erfahrungen
weitergeben und vor allem auch auf meine
media kanäle sich der positive energie
verbreiten kann und weiß auch in
schweren situationen noch mal helfen
kann
durch meine erlebnisse ist das gab es
auch etwas was wir gesellschaftlich
braucht man die aktuelle situation war
sicher für dich nicht einfach wir kommen
ja auch gleich auf die verschiebung der
paralympics aber dass du als
behindertensportler auch genau diese
botschaften übersenden kannst das auch
etwas wo da gab es dass du damit auch
einen fußabdruck hinterlassen kannst
auch in split klingt oder einen reifen
abgleich unserer gesellschaft ja ich
versuche es also es ist natürlich schön
wenn man mit jemandem unterhalten und er
sagt ich finde das cool was du machst
und das motiviert mich auch das bringt
mich weiter und das ist für mich dann
wunderschön also wenn ich dann einen
bleibenden eindruck hinterlassen kann
wieder auf einen positiven bei dieser
story und wollen wir uns jetzt in so
schwierigen zeiten wie mit der aktuellen
krise ist wenn man da was positives
findet über das man sich unterhalten
kann oder dass wir einen anderen zu
etwas motivieren kann
und ist das denke ich schon ganz gut du
bist mental ihr sind starke so richtig
kennengelernt
wir haben auch erlebnisse wo du den kopf
schritt denn dass es die nervösen
manchen wettkämpfen aber auf jeden fall
qualifiziert sich zum ersten mal für
deine paralympics in tokio du freust
dich darauf die quali phase war
irrsinnig
anstrengend irrsinnig komplex wir waren
so erleichtert sie es beide geschafft
haben und dann heißt es spiele werden
verschoben wie ist es dir in dem moment
gegangen ja ich gemischte gefühle
dadurch dass natürlich die pandemie ganz
aktuell ist muss man aus
gesundheitlichen und menschlicher sicht
sagen das ist eine gute entscheidung war
als sportlicher sicht ist natürlich
schade ich habe mich extrem gerade auf
meine ersten spiele das ist das ziel sei
mit dem schwimmen begonnen habe die
leute zu mir gesagt ob das nicht ein
bisschen ein hohes ziel ist habe ich ihn
so man kann das noch immer zurück
schaffte aber es ist einfach mein
lebensziel will ich hin und jetzt habe
ich es wirklich geschafft sich zu
qualifizieren
natürlich schön wenn es auch stattfinden
würden von mir ist alles erledigt jetzt
müssen es nur mehr stattfinden ja
schauen also die quali phase war extrem
hart dass wir als teamkollegen gemeinsam
noch wettkämpfe überall bestritten auf
der ganzen welt dass wir das gemeinsam
schaffen
nach der absage war bei uns beiden die
sorge der qualifikation jetzt vielleicht
nicht mehr gültig ist für uns was ein
großes thema war aber nach dem ist ein
klasse und das wird trotzdem weiterhin
von dürfen denke ich mal wieder sehr
erleichtert und jetzt müssen wir schauen
erstens wir die pandemie weiter geht und
zweitens wirst du mit dem spiel nächstes
jahr auch passiert wir hoffen natürlich
dass die stattfinden das wir beide dort
schnell sind aber ich freue mich auf
jeden fall auf deine leistung und bin
mir sicher dass es nicht bei den spielen
bleiben motiviert etwas zu früh auch
erwähnt dass seine feuerwehrkollegen die
während der unfallzeit auch sehr zur
seite gestanden sind und du bist ja
immer noch bei der feuerwehr aktiv wie
können wir uns das genau vorstellt ich
bin schon einige erfolge bei der
freiwilligen feuerwehr zwar gern dabei
gewesen und dem ich dann eben sehr
motiviert noch mal umfallen mich da nie
fallen lassen quasi und das war für mich
schon komisch weil ich hier meine ich
gedacht dass ich jetzt aufgrund mein
rollstuhl eigentlich bei einer
freiwilligen feuerwehr nichts mehr
verloren
ich kann einfach nicht mehr in diesem
notfall geschehen und im einsatz leben
dabei sein was soll ich dort noch also
überhaupt nicht so der mich voll
mitgezogen mich motiviert zu
mittlerweile dann nicht sogar vor ein
paar jahren eine verantwortungslose
aktion geben wenn jetzt dort
sachbearbeiter für die
öffentlichkeitsarbeit so alles was mit
öffentlichkeitsarbeit zu tun hat
übernehme ich ist das jetzt die
presseaussendung von größeren einsätzen
im presse kommunikation am einsatzort
unsere und wird uns was social media
kanäle das mache ich alles und für mich
ist die feuerwehr einfach
unbeschreiblich also von meiner seite
das würde ich auf keinen fall aufhören
ich bin froh dass nämlich auch behalten
haben dann weiß ich jetzt noch mal dass
ich jetzt auch eine aufgabe habe die
sinnvoll ist wo ich wirklich was machen
kann und es ist sogar so dass ich jetzt
nach meinem volk sogar schon wieder bei
einsatz dabei war und in der hand eines
leitungen helfen können
also das ist nicht mehr möglich was ich
gedacht habe was was war denn dafür
alles zu verändern damit es eben nicht
unmöglich ist weil auf den ersten blick
würde man sagen ja das geht halt nicht
man kann nicht mehr einfach als
rollstuhlfahrer beim einsatz dabei sein
weil der einsatz wahrscheinlich nicht so
konzipiert ist dass das funktioniert was
haben sie ändern müssen damit das
möglich gemacht wird damit du erstens
jetzt bei einsätzen auch dabei sein kann
es aber zweitens auch eine
verantwortungsvolle in der freiwilligen
phase übernehmen konnte
wenn man erster einsatz war das
eigentlich island zufall war ich gerade
zufällig im feuerwehrhaus war die
alarmierung reinkommen ist und für meine
kameraden war sofort klar dass nämlich
mitnehmen einsatz nämlich geschnappt
haben einen rollstuhl um welchen
einsatzleiter fahrzeug setzen wir zum
einsatzort gefahren und ich hab dann
dort zu sluiter fahrzeug besetzt und
mittlerweile so dass wenn ich einen
jungen bekommt dann zu größeren
einsätzen selber privaten vermieter und
haben die sache und ich brauche meine
mutter mitbekommen und so zum 1 1 taten
kann und dort sind wir da helfen in der
einsatzleitung unterstützen oder im die
presse kommunikation
je nachdem was gerade anfällt und
konsole gottseidank wolle man einen
beitrag leisten dass das klingt so als
wäre jetzt gar nicht die umstände oder
die rahmenbedingungen so essenziell
sondern eigentlich nur der wille also
deine kollegen backen einen rollstuhl
mitte und habe nicht in den einsatzwagen
und du bist halt dabei also wenn der
wille da ist dass man das möchte
dann funktioniert das sehr wohl glaubst
du dass wir das als gesellschaft auch in
anderen gesellschaftlichen lagen genau
so bräuchten diesen wählen ja die packen
und das geht auf jeden fall ja das ist
etwas was mir geholfen hat weil das
immer das feuerwerk sehen ob ich den
rollstuhl für mich dann cup war für mich
schon vieles unmöglich muss ich alles
sagen weil ich jetzt nicht mehr gehen
können und was wird einfach fehlen immer
gegangen ist aber der feuerwehr war nie
irgendwas er sich nicht mit verrät
können
das heißt dass irgendeiner ergo
ein anderes event vertreten das war
nicht die frage ob ich mitkommen kann
oder nicht sondern ob ich mitkommen will
oder nicht wenn ich sage ich will mir
kommen haben die irgendein weg gefunden
wenn es mich zum beispiel wir haben eine
tierrettung auszeichnung bekommt man im
wiener rathaus und dann möchte dort
stiegen auf tragen also das ist einfach
es gibt nichts was nicht geht wenn ich
mit der feuerwehr unterwegs bin bin ich
sehr froh das hat man auch sehr geholfen
das hat dem sich die dinge nur an dass
ich sehe mich jetzt nicht unbedingt sehr
eingeschränkt im rollstuhl
ich bin froh dass es mir gut geht und
dass ich alles machen kann und das kann
natürlich auch den menschen in anderen
situationen helfen was man vielleicht
nicht in erster linie eine ausrede für
irgendwas findet mit ok da ist er das
und das nämlich als ausrede und dadurch
habe ich alles nicht machen können
sollten wir vielleicht zwischen den
vielen möglichen aus werden was findet
irgendeine begründung dass man das
vielleicht doch kann damit der sich
motiviert das vielleicht irgendwann
durchzuziehen oder zumindest zu
probieren
du bist jetzt auch genau wenn du mit
anderen menschen spricht wahrscheinlich
in situation dass wenn du erzählst dass
du herr sportler bist und dann
wahrscheinlich auf die frage kommt daher
wie geht das überhaupt
es ist ja für uns so dass wir keine
grundausbildung in dem sinne machen
mussten sondern sozusagen direkt in den
dienst wandern welche reaktionen
siehst du da und und die antwort dass du
ihnen dass es doch funktioniert
eigentlich verschiedenste situationen so
wie du sagst mach ich jetzt eigentlich
geht das so piste und da gilt was machst
du beim bundesheer wobei das aber die
wenigsten sind die meisten bei denen ich
sagt sicherheit sportler bin ich weiß
man sofort die augen aber so geil das
geht und cool freut mich mega und finden
das auch sehr gut vom bundesheer dass
die das für uns vor ein paar jahren
geschafft haben dass wir genau sagen
könne wie die nichtbehinderten und ich
finde dass vor allem das bundesheer logo
wenn wir das tragen dass das im prinzip
waren bislang qualitätszeichen ist in
der bevölkerung nun wieder das
behindertensportler zu unserer sportler
ausgeben das ist quasi ein
qualitätsmerkmal das wir profisportler
sind dass wir nicht der therapie mäßig
plan schon gehen sie jetzt machen
sondern dass wir das wirklich
professionell machen und auf einem
leistungsniveau und mit dem ziel der
österreicher gut zu vertreten auch
erfolge zu machen dass auch dein studium
schon angesprochen was studierst du
genau und warum studierst du das
studiere medizinische informatik auf der
tu wien
ja ist ein bisserl abwegig schwimmsport
es ist so dass ich vor dem unfall einen
traumberuf nur aus dem hubschrauber
abkommen den brauch durch die feuerwehr
habe ich das einsatz geschenk in den
ländern das hätte ich extrem gemacht
jetzt im rollstuhl werde ich kenne oder
den hubschrauber werden dass man mal
schnell klar da war die frage ob ich
medizinstudium arzt wehrt aber das ganze
einsatz gestimmt fällt weg und dass ich
jetzt nur in einem krankenhaus von
zimmer zu zimmer gehen und schauen was
los ist das ist jetzt nicht die art von
was ich werden wollte und ich habe eine
htl informatik gemacht das habe ich auch
ganz gut können eigentlich und das wäre
schade gewesen dass jetzt wegzuschmeißen
und im prinzip habe ich das mit der
medizinischen informatik die perfekte
kombination von dem was mich
interessiert und den man sich keinen
gefunden und die studios jetzt nebenbei
geht es langsam nehmen sport aber es
geht mir darum dass ich einfach was auch
wenn der sport an dem mann vorbei ist
dass ich dann was habe wo ich arbeiten
gehen kann und wo siehst du dich da was
würde dich da so interessieren was
wirklich reizen dass kurse für mich wäre
wenn ich eben in die bereiche forschung
noch irgendwas mit meinem unfall gehen
kann habe ich den vorteil dass ich
erstens informatik kennt zweitens die
medizinische seite kennen durch das
studium betreten sich auch noch die
erfahrung von hagens unfall habe ich
glaube das zeichnet mich dann ziemlich
aus und dann bin ich auf einmal nicht
irgendwo benachteiligen einer
behinderung sondern auch kein vorteil
und wenn ich dadurch immer sofort was
dann anderen leuten auch noch viel
vielleicht schon ähnliche verletzung
haben und vielleicht sogar irgendwann
querschnittslähmung geheilt werden kann
wenn ich dabei sein könnt mit dem team
das wäre natürlich unglaublich und
ganzen ganz ein großes ziel und bis
dahin natürlich noch weiter im sport
dass die paralympics als lebenstraum
ausgegeben
du bist irrsinnig jung du bist auch in
deiner karriere noch sehr am anfang und
da ist noch viel vor dir was hast du dir
alles vorgenommen für die zukunft vor
auf können wir uns einstellen von dir
noch zu hören andreas gold bei den
paralympics brechen ja also bin ich auf
jeden fall kein medaillenkandidat das
habe ich aber vor zwei jahren bei der
europameisterschaft auch gesagt und dann
haben sie mir das ist seitdem
schließlich so was nie wieder aus es
kann so viel passieren gerade uns im
schwimmsport da geht es um hundertstel
und ob ich einen guten tag aber nicht
schön was natürlich schon den nächsten
jahr irgendeine modelle klingeln
aber du sagst ich bin noch jung ich habe
noch viel zeit ich werde gott sei dank
bis jetzt jedes jahr schneller und
schneller kann meine eigenen rekord
pulverisieren
und spätestens 2024 in paris wäre es
natürlich super wenn da was goldenes mit
nach hause fliegen kann ist das auch
etwas wo du sagst damit könnte ich
wirklich das was ich immer erreichen
wollte wirklich abhaken und sagen dass
das wars oder bist du das dann als
befeuert weitermachen vor allem in
richtung seiner mentalen stärke die du
hast dass du wirklich damit auch deine
erfolge holen kannst er ist sehr schwer
zu sagen das ist natürlich das große
ziel wenn es dann mal passiert wie man
darauf reagiert es schwer zu sagen jetzt
kann ich sagen das ist als sportler weiß
dass man sagt man hat genug auch wenn
ich jetzt zu dem zeitpunkt der beste bin
dann will ich das nächste jahr wieder
der beste sein und der schnellste der
welt es ist das schwer dass man jetzt
sagt er hat genug dann gibt es natürlich
noch das mal weltrekordhalter sein will
und wird immer eine stufe was man noch
aufsteigen kann
war ja dass die mentale wenn es
natürlich auch ganz wichtig und da geht
es nicht jetzt das glück dass meine
mutter sportpsychologin ist mich da von
anfang an betreut hat das hat man sicher
geholfen dass man eine klärung so steil
nach oben gegangen ist und gleich bei
der ersten meisterschaft eine medaille
da war
und ja so geht's dahin wenn wir ja dann
bist du natürlich eine optimale
situation auch dass du von deiner
eigenen mutter in dem bereich betreut
werden kann
herzlichen dank auf jeden fall für die
einblicke in eine spannende karriere bis
jetzt auch in deine sichtweise auf
behinderung auf unsere gesellschaft und
dass du damit auch etwas bewegen
möchtest bleibe auf jeden fall gesund
weiterhin alles gute und danke dass du
heute mit dabei ist dankeschön
ja danke euch für das dabei sein ich
hoffe ihr habt spannende einblicke in
das leben von andreas helfer bekommen
das ist das was wir beim sport report
euch zeigen wollen sagt auch beim
nächsten mal wieder mit dabei bis dann
und servus
[Musik]
[Applaus]